hello and welcome to this video playing
a plus cave okay so I last time I think
he outplayed me very nicely in an
Italian game at least that it's not
happening I'm going to have something
else okay this way think I'll take him
yeah get a line of the declined banco
here which is some believe to be and
something between equal and slide it
better for white we'll see how things
unfold so nine to five or maybe 95 here
right so i can take on c4 here one i
wonder if this is actually a good idea
or not um can also go Queen to be six or
something and it doesn't really lead to
much i would like to move my knight of
course this one and you just take and
you should try to get rid of this okay
so we actually doesn't mind the trades
this is something that i also don't mind
in general in those bank or positions or
bodoni type of position sir black should
be usually quite happy with one or two
sets of pieces traded okay here if he
wants to do this typical attack but
should be four comes into consideration
I'm Johnny 5 f-5 so I'm checking the
cause of this and put this here so
Queen j5 ya kun je five looks good
threatening would be two words okay
that's easily oops it's not doing
something about that why why isn't that
that working so the ship takes okay okay
okay Queen takes is getting rupee seven
at the end wow it's a pretty cool
decision or you just blundered it i mean
it's also possible you don't know
because this this doesn't look totally
clear to me at least at first so Knight
f6 you will play rookie 7i guess okay or
i go to be six that's the other option
rupee six route d8 also comes into
consideration okay seven and then King
f8 or something like no I can actually
do this let's do this look a seven-night
f6 trying to win the upon I'm not sure
if I should go for the e point or the C
porn rookie 7i f king of eight and then
grab your form really unsure about this
of course yeah that's possible okay do I
play the double capture I guess I done
then put it here still if I play rockin
of a truck moves I cannot move stuff the
deep on is dangerous somewhat dangerous
and the rukon the seventh is an
extremely it's extremely annoying king
of eight I can still not move my knight
really a big issue I have look a 4d six
really not sure he ever can if I can do
that DC cupcakes you see promoting it
i'm not sure about it how can i have to
play now i'm down on time you might be
able to promote the pawn couldn't
calculate that fully so the check first
check and should be helpful anyway okay
so look d to know this l have kept king
ism I can still give them a couple of
checks here time money and now i can
still not move the bloody night if I
check in mia it's got King you one
unfortunately I've got no time d7 King
yourself check
still this is still covered bloody
murder cannot do much chef
check check check check yeah I didn't
have much all those checks this guy is
very irritating very irritating land for
a fence on time so we just allows this
stuff won't be too and it has a present
position against I after that this is
hard to accept I mean okay the engine
has black totally winds this pollution
but it's difficult it's difficult and I
didn't quite could it I couldn't make it
work so Knight f6 okay the engine wants
to do this which I did not have on the
right at all yeah 93 is probably an idea
here what is the deal i wrote the aid
the engine just wants to wants to get an
attack with all those pieces okay the
engine gives a total win ian from black
hoods I couldn't really I didn't figure
it out I was thinking maybe this is just
too lame I wanted to to do it like that
and this of course I didn't didn't have
on the right out I mean sort of but had
no solution for it Nyjah force again
winning for black and this and this
isn't all that clear this isn't all that
clear so this is this okay okay okay but
can I say an engine says I'm winning
this game here clearly even check but I
couldn't couldn't do it okay
just take edge to now it seems the point
isn't all that dangerous ah this is the
thing King e8 and then 97 this is this I
didn't see at all aha why does that even
work
and try to figure this out here so this
is the engines line it's possible that
white simply has nothing I mean
obviously it is the case as the engine
gives me minus 3 but but how do I
actually win this I mean okay the engine
i can give you this line the computer
line check it's just totally unfazed
here okay now i actually win the deep
one okay then it is fairly easy I guess
yeah I don't know I was the shadows
deeply irritated to him check and now
check it's a draw according to the
machine with the sea pawn push but I had
no time whatsoever and sacrifice and now
i'm probably losing yeah 0.5 for what
but okay the time was impossible to do i
just i think this is the game that I
lost against him like like a week or so
I had some plates and roll down because
he completely outplayed me down
irritating that he played all that so
quickly like it was a grand scheme or
anything and it just rubbish I wonder if
actually I mean okay i understand that
this is a win technically speaking with
I wondered actually if I can do the
sources to terms too lame here
engine still thinks I'm winning this but
I'm not quite sure him I think I'm okay
I mean that the cleanest is probably
this and go for the attack that looks
quite quite strong but now that was not
on my radar at all ok guys thanks for
watching